tuve una revelación que cambió mi vida.
Era pintor y decorador
en Castlemaine, una pequeña ciudad en el centro de Victoria.
Había ido a ver a Pete, que era reconocido por su trabajo con el acero.
Había ido a su galpón por ribete de acero para el jardín.
Ese día, retrospectivamente, fue un gran regalo.
Pete parecía más feliz de lo usual.
Dos semanas después,
estaba pintando una casa al final de la calle de Pete
cuando me enteré de las malas noticias.
Pete se había suicidado.
Pete, como yo, era un técnico o trabajador en casas.
Nos gusta acortar las palabras en el australiano vernáculo.
Un técnico.
Se esperaban ciertas cosas de un técnico.
Se espera que seas estoico.
Se espera que seas fuerte,
enérgico y macho.
Se espera que seas fuerte físicamente
y callado ante la adversidad.
Se produce un efecto dominó
cuando hay un suicidio en la comunidad.
El funeral de Pete fue en julio. Era invierno.
El ambiente era triste y sombrío
en la atestada sala comunitaria.
Era una comunidad afligida
que no tenía respuestas
al suicidio de Pete.
Ninguna respuesta.
Mientras deambulaba entre los técnicos y los miembros de la comunidad,
empecé a escuchar algunos comentarios que reflejaban otro nivel trágico subyacente.
En esa sala comunitaria escuché a personas hablar
de los problemas que otros estaban pasando.
La esencia de esas conversaciones era resumida en dos palabras
qué escuché varias veces:
¿Quién sigue?
Esa fue la revelación.
Fue en ese momento cuando estaba parado en la sala comunitaria
en ese lugar donde esta comunidad de Castlemaine
me había apoyado durante 20 años,
había respaldado mi trabajo, había jugado fútbol australiano ahí,
había actuado ahí.
Estaba muy agradecido por lo que me habían dado.
Estaba parado ahí en ese lugar
y miraba alrededor de esa sala
y podía identificar entre ellos
quiénes tenían problemas con el alcohol, drogas, dinero, apuestas,
violencia doméstica, acoso y hostigamiento.
Pero debido a mi cultura como técnico
y esa actitud ignorante que tenemos en la comunidad de técnicos
no me sentía con confianza.
No tenía las herramientas. Me faltaba experiencia.
No sabía qué hacer pero quería hacer algo.
Salí del funeral.
Abracé a algunos compañeros técnicos y les dije:
"Si lo necesitas, ven a verme, por favor".
Pero no sabía qué decirles. No tenía ni idea.
Dos semanas después recibí una llamada de Catherina Pilgrim, la cofundadora,
que quería que hiciera algo por la familia.
Hablamos un rato y le dije:
Hagamos algo por la comunidad de técnicos.
Amamos nuestro pueblo, estamos agradecidos.
Hablamos un poco más.
¿Qué podíamos hacer?
Un evento de concientización. Increíble.
Estamos hablando de técnicos.
¿Cómo reúnes a técnicos en algún lugar?
¿Se puede hacerlos ir a un hospital? No.
¿A un centro comunitario de salud? No.
Hay una arraigada cultura en ser un técnico.
Pensé en cuál podría ser el lugar ideal para reunirlos
donde se sintieran incluidos,
cómodos,
y pudieran compartir, abrirse y hablar sobre salud mental
en el sector de la construcción.
¿Dónde podríamos tener ese evento?
Una ferretería.
(Risas)
Sí, eso fue también lo que pensé, que era muy acertado.
Para ser precisos, en el depósito de madera de la ferretería.
Ahí estábamos. Encontramos el lugar.
¿Qué más necesitábamos?
¿Qué otra cosa aman los técnicos?
Comida.
Lo sé, así es para todos.
Pero en especial para los técnicos y yo soy uno.
Nos encanta los huevos y los rollos de tocino.
Pensamos en ofrecer eso a los técnicos
y teníamos un eslogan:
Guarda tu tocino.
Es un poco cursi pero funciona.
Además, se nos ocurrió un logo.
"Hope Assistance Local Tradies", HALT.
Tengan en mente que "HALT", nuestra institución benéfica,
no tenía fondos para comenzar;
nada, ni un centavo.
Entablamos conversaciones.
Es una problemática de la comunidad. Empieza en la comunidad.
Así que fuimos al carnicero y al panadero,
no había ningún fabricante de velas,
había un sitio de huevos, había chocolate,
café, frutas,
dimos vueltas y dijimos:
"Estamos haciendo un evento de concientización.
¿Les gustaría aportar? Puesto que no tenemos nada de dinero".
Claro, casi todas las personas con las que hablamos
conocían a alguien que sufría de ansiedad, depresión o tenía pensamientos suicidas
o que se hubiera suicidado.
Había una unidad,
un abordaje comunitario.
Pensamos que eso era increíble, teníamos comida.
¿Qué otra cosa se requería?
Necesitábamos servicios de asistencia.
Muchos técnicos, y en su mayoría hombres
no saben a dónde ir a obtener ayuda.
Yo mismo era uno de esos
y esto fue de lo que hablé en los eventos HALT:
que hace cuatro años cuando fundé HALT,
no sabía que podía ir al médico a tratar mi salud mental
y recibir un plan para eso.
No sabía sobre salud comunitaria.
Indudablemente no sabía sobre Lifeline,
y he contactado Lifeline tres veces
y ellos en verdad me han salvado la vida.
Tuve que aprender todas estas cosas.
Los técnicos tienen que saberlas.
Les dimos bolsas,
bolsas que incluyen información
y en el primer año hubo algunos técnicos que me dijeron:
"Esto es una carga de ya sabes qué",
pero yo sé que esos técnicos todavía tienen esas bolsas en sus camionetas
o en sus galpones.
El 10 de noviembre de 2013
tuvimos nuestro evento.
Es curioso, cuando hablo de un abordaje comunitario,
ese fue nuestro primer evento en Tonks Brothers, Castlemaine,
y hay una gran comunidad ahí.
Había consejeros,
había personas que habían sufrido enfermedades mentales.
Ese primer evento marcó la pauta.
Desde entonces hemos tenido más eventos.
Curiosamente, no solo los técnicos son afectados en su salud mental,
o sufren de ansiedad, de depresión o suicidio.
Empezamos a trabajar con TAFE.
Empezamos a trabajar en el sector agrícola,
en asambleas, en escuelas secundarias.
Hicimos eventos para las parejas de los técnicos
porque en ocasiones los técnicos no irán a casa
y le dirán a su pareja: "adivina qué, hablamos sobre salud mental
y ahora haremos esto, esto y esto".
Así que estamos haciendo esos eventos para las parejas
que quizás necesiten ayuda.
Los TAFE son muy conocidos.
Para mí, es crucial llegar a esos hombres y mujeres jóvenes y vulnerables.
Hemos hecho eventos para hombres.
El nivel de suicidios es realmente alto en hombres mayores.
Hemos realizado eventos para los obreros y los técnicos.
Curiosamente,
casi cada uno de los eventos...
en realidad, lo hemos hecho con pocos fondos
150 eventos en cuatro estados.
Así que... oh, bien, gracias.
(Aplausos)
Invariablemente, en cada uno de los eventos HALT en una ferretería,
un técnico se me acercaba,
al menos uno se me acercaba y me contaba sobre su intento de suicidio.
No eran suicidas en ese momento, ya lo habían superado,
pero estos hombres jamás habían sentido que podían compartir sus debilidades.
Sentían que nunca podían hablar sobre su intento de suicidio,
pero los eventos HALT,
donde no había ninguna expectativa de que hablaran,
lo hacían sentir cómodos para hablar.
No es solo que hablaran conmigo y me contaran su historia,
de hecho, ahora dicen:
"Nos sentimos cómodos de hablar con otros hombres".
Hubo hombres que dijeron:
"Yo nunca antes había dicho que tengo depresión, pero la tengo,
y si alguien más aquí quiere hablar conmigo,
estoy aquí para hablar".
Te da confianza y es catártico hacer eso.
Necesitamos un abordaje comunitario.
Dimos a los técnicos información sobre servicios de apoyo locales y nacionales.
Una de las cosas que le decimos a un técnico o alguien en estos eventos es:
"Tú puedes ir aquí, aquí y aquí",
pero se necesita a toda la comunidad
para acoger la idea de la prevención al suicidio.
Necesitamos esos servicios,
el suicidio no discrimina.
No es algo de 9 a 17.
Necesitamos hacer eventos antes de las 9, donde aún estamos en receso,
y después de las 17.
Es lo que necesitamos hacer; es un abordaje comunitario.
Necesitamos entrar en los negocios.
Necesitamos entrar en los clubes deportivos y comunitarios.
Necesitamos entrar allí y capacitar a las personas
para entender sobre salud mental.
Aquí tenemos unas serias estadísticas para que se hagan una idea.
En el 2016,
en Australia hubo 2866 suicidios
casi el doble que las muertes por accidente automovilísticos.
A nivel global hay 800 000 suicidios al año en el mundo,
uno cada 40 segundos.
Se necesita la participación de toda la comunidad.
Necesitamos sentirnos cómodos para entablar conversaciones.
Con los hombres que conozco es muy difícil tener esa apertura al conversar.
En verdad es así.
Les digo a los chicos que si van a entablar una conversación
necesitan encontrar un lugar cómodo para tener esa apertura y conversar,
ya sea un bar, durante una caminata,
después del fútbol.
Encuentren un lugar cómodo para la conversación.
Parte de la capacidad de tener esa conversación
es saber qué decir.
Todos hemos oído: "¿Estás bien?"
Lo he visto. Lo he hecho.
"¿Estás bien?" "Sí". "¿Estás bien?" "Sí".
"¿Estás bien?" "Sí". "¿Estás bien?" "No".
¿Qué digo ahora?
¿Qué digo?
Necesitamos dotar a cada persona
con la capacidad de salir y poder entablar esa conversación.
Necesitamos ser capaces de escuchar.
No sé quién es buen oyente aquí.
Estoy trabajando en mi capacidad de escucha,
pero escuchar sin juzgar es un arte.
No se burlen; si alguien viene a hablar con Uds. sobre su enfermedad mental,
su ansiedad, depresión o de sus pensamientos suicidas,
debemos respetar eso.
Ellos quieren confiar en que nosotros vamos a mantener el secreto
y no se lo contaremos a nadie.
Debemos respetar eso.
Debemos conversar. Debemos escuchar.
Debemos empezar a reducir el estigma asociado a la salud mental.
Ahora las empresas están implementando días para la salud mental.
¡Qué gran idea!
No son solo días de enfermedad física; son días de salud mental.
Las cosas están cambiando. Podemos sumarnos a ese cambio.
Preservo vidas.
Y pienso que todos podemos preservar vidas.
El dolor del arrepentimiento
es mucho mayor que el dolor del trabajo arduo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)